my name is kevin adey and i'm the chef
and owner of faro in bushwick brooklyn
and today we're going to make three
different pastas using different amounts
of ingredients all with about the same
difficulty level i do love pasta i'm a
noodle maniac
uh we're gonna jump right in and start
with our first pasta by tossing a little
butter in the pan but we're really gonna
take butter to another level hidden
inside of all butter is brown butter
we're gonna get that brown butter out by
cooking it at a generous clip here and
the butter will transform and the
sizzling is going down i can also start
to smell it starting to work so at this
point we're going to throw in our sage
leaves you want to keep moving around
scraping as you go on the bottom of the
pan to ensure even browning you can
start to see the color change there at
this point you have nice crispy sage
leaves we're going to add pasta water in
to stop the cooking you don't need a
whole symphony of ingredients to make a
great pasta dish this is simplicity at
its finest next up we're going to go
with our scarpernock pasta scarpanoc is
what we use at faro it's from bergamo
north of milan it's a basic filled pasta
i know this is more than uh you know
just two ingredients but any pasta will
work here i think a filled one would be
the best for this pasta you can use a
store-bought tortellini or raviolis from
the frozen food section whatever you're
in the mood for this just happens to be
what i have and what i like and we're
just going to throw in our scarpies we
started our past water with just a
little bit of semolina already in it it
helps with the water being more
conducive for a sauce afterwards at the
restaurant we don't have to do it
because we're cooking you know hundreds
of orders of pasta at night but you know
when you're doing it one time thing
throw a little bit of flour in it it's
not going to hurt it in fact it's
probably going to help this pasta cooked
from fresh took about three minutes
okay so you can see our pasta
sauce has now come up to temperature
it's finished and beautiful and at this
point we're just going to slide in our
filled pasta and we're going to give it
a quick shake
you can see you don't need to get crazy
you know tossing it slapping it around
this is you know very simple stuff that
we're just going to keep together like
this and we're going to go from right
here right to the plate you want to
definitely give it some time in the pan
and it will uh pick up a little bit of
that pasta water and the um some of the
butter flavor our crispy sage right on
top and there you have it this is a
three ingredient pasta that's definitely
greater than some of its parts
scarpernock brown butter and sage if you
just got home from work or you're having
a dinner party these smells are gonna
overwhelm you and take the stress out of
your day it's definitely comfort food to
the max sometimes simple is the absolute
best way to end your day and it doesn't
get much simpler than this all right i'm
going to give this a taste test and
we'll compare all three at the end all
right up next is our second pasta this
is frascatelli it's from southern italy
it's really super easy to make first
thing you want to do i just grab the
water and let it drizzle naturally out
of your hand shake the uh semo as you go
there's no right and wrong you just
don't want to pour the water you want to
have little drops this is just you know
an organic semolina coarse milled
instead of water it can be done with egg
wine milk anything you want this is a
real rudimentary ancient style of pasta
all pasta comes from the word impasta
which means to knead or to work and this
has none of it it's one of the very few
pastas that doesn't actually have a
dough
and then using your handy dandy strainer
like magic you end up with little
frascatelli you want to make these and
then cook it pretty directly like mining
for gold that's it this is the
frascatelli right here you know full
portion of pasta in less than five
minutes black pepper and that farro we
use a mixture of three different peppers
this is just your plain old like
telecherry black peppercorns you can
find at any grocery store we also use
long pepper and camp hot pepper we're
gonna toss these in the pan until they
get nice and fragrant you definitely
don't need to have your own proprietary
blend of peppercorns to make this dish
just straight black pepper from the
grocery store will work fantastically
you don't want to burn the pepper that's
a critical error medium heat medium low
take your time enjoy yourself now that
your peppercorns are toasted and super
fragrant we want to
kill the heat and go right into a mortar
and pestle if you don't have a mortar
and pestle that's okay too you can put
it into a pepper mill and grind it
yourself if for some reason you don't
have a peppermill you can put it right
on the board and use the back of the pan
to smash it down yourself we're just
going to give them a very light smash
here okay the goal is not dust you can
see nice and coarse strain out any dust
it's gonna make the final dish super
cloudy you're not gonna need all of this
but it's good to have more than you need
we're gonna keep cooking this this is
not the only cook that we're doing on
this okay we're gonna start building our
sauce for our pasta first thing we're
gonna put in the pan is guanchale
guanchali it's an unsmoked cured pork
cheek you can use bacon if you wanted to
you could use pancetta any kind of cured
pork is uh traditional we're just gonna
get it rendering nice and slowly the
length of time that you spend rendering
the natural sugars in the meat take to
caramelize and the better
result you're gonna find at the end the
pork is up to a sizzle here at this
point we're gonna put in our black
pepper and now you can really start to
smell the work that you're putting in i
really feel like no matter if you're
cooking with two ingredients or ten it's
about building one on top of another
working these two ingredients together
creates a really nice base you know for
the pyramid if you don't have the base
stuff built properly the building's
gonna end up falling down you know it's
not hard to see how this is gonna
transform into something even bigger
than its parts just by putting a little
bit of care into these first two
ingredients i think we're at the point
where we're gonna stop this cooking so
we're gonna take some of our reserved
pasta water and glaze the pan then we
will move on with the pasta frascatelli
like any other fresh pasta it's going to
cook very quickly with no kneading it's
just a wondermint of the pasta world
we're good here our pepper pasta water
and pork product are up to a simmer we
want to go in right in with your
frascata this is how you're going to
finish your cooking so while this
reduces we're going to separate our egg
this will be used later for garnish in
the finishing of the dish nice single
yolk and we're just going to put that
into
a little extra pasta water just to bring
the temperature up temper the yolk and
you can see here the frascata's getting
a little bit tighter with the sauce in
the pan starting to get you know looking
like a finished pasta at this point
we're gonna add in some pecorino some
parm
and we're going to stir it together
you hear that that's what good pasta
sounds like now that you know you've got
beautiful pasta it's come together all
nice we're going to add in just a little
bit of butter it's going to help shine
it up you don't have to go too crazy
here we serve this pasta on the tasting
menu at faro i've been told people will
come after me with pitchforks if i take
this off the menu so this is always on
the menu and we're going to go right to
the plate quickly you want you know hot
food hot plate frescatelli in the bowl
and then we are going to garnish this
pasta with a tempered egg yolk just to
finish we're going to give it another
little sprinkling of cheese fresh cheese
and a turn of fresh pepper
not too much i know we have a lot in
there there's the finished dish
frascatelli a la carbonara made with
cured pork cheese black pepper egg and
pasta okay moving on to our final pasta
we're going to make chicha mariti first
thing we're going to do is cut the dough
into dowels you know like letting things
rest that time really helps you if the
dough isn't right in the beginning
you're doomed from the start you know
patience is really an ingredient in all
pasta making so now that we have our
dowels and they're all basically equal
size we're going to cut little even
equal pieces to make the chamorro tea
the way i do it is i put my hands
together like this and you just throw
them out like that chimeriti is from
lazio in the hills surrounding rome
traditionally made also with a little
bit of leftover bread dough so it has a
little bit of leavening to it sometimes
there's wine in the dough this we do
with a basic hand dough at farrell you
want to find the hole in the palm of
your hand when you put your two two
together it creates like a little pocket
that's that shape and you just end up
with this little you know pasta mustache
cheicha moriti actually means husband
blinder as in if you serve these pastas
to your husband that he'll never look at
another person i didn't make them to
blind anybody i think that they're just
delicious you also wouldn't believe how
many pastas are named after blinding
something in italy if you don't want to
do it on both hands it can be done like
this i'm going to continue making the
pasta and we'll be back in a moment with
the finished product for our last pasta
the cheicha morati we're going to start
the same way we did with the previous
with a little bit of diced up won
chocolate this sauce you're definitely
going to want a little bit more of a
sizzle in the pan a little hotter pan a
little faster action is going to help
this into this pork we're going to put
ground pork and this ground pork in that
already rendered out pork fat
is the crux of the whole operation here
getting this golden brown delicious gbd
we call it golden brown and delicious
you only have one chance to
to get this meat where you want it to be
so we're gonna take our time with it
temperature control is pretty important
at this point here you want to make sure
the pan's hot but not so hot that you're
gonna burn burn the meat all right so
this is what we're looking for here nice
caramelized pork and when we get to that
point give it one last little stir get
everything off the bottom and then we're
gonna remove the pork from this pan but
not not wash it out okay we're gonna
leave any bits that are stuck to the
bottom we're gonna go back into the pork
fat that's remaining in the pan with
sofrito which is for us
celery carrot onion all finely minced
you can even use a cheese grater for
this the finer you make it the more it
disappears into the sauce also a little
bit of garlic whenever you make a ragu
it's really important that you season as
you go but you don't want to start
adding salt until you get your
caramelization we've got a nice little
cook going here on our sofrito
at this point we are going to add in
this is a mixture of ground cumin
coriander fennel seed and black pepper
adding these layers of flavor these base
layers of flavor in abundance now are
going to pay off in a couple hours now
we've kind of bloomed our hard spices at
this point we're gonna go in with a
little bit of flavoring chilies we're
still caramelizing it's nice and
beautiful we're gonna add in a little
bit of tomato paste and this we want to
really cook
into the sofrito you know you have to
build these flavors it takes just as
long to make it bad as it does to make
it good so you know take your time do it
step by step and now that we've got our
tomato paste caramelized we're going to
add some reduced red wine i reduce it
first this is an entire bottle of red
wine gets that deep dark wine flavor in
there so now in with
beef demi-glaze at this point we're
turning the pork to the bowl we got that
reduced red wine color we're gonna add a
sachet bay leaf parsley thyme we're also
gonna season at this point okay a little
bit more pepper we're gonna give it a
stir and we're gonna turn it down to a
bare simmer it's very important that you
you have a reverence for every little
bit of what you're doing here you know
if you're going to do all this work and
then not care about the
herbs and you put in a sandy piece of
parsley it'll ruin the whole dish you're
going to have the time on this one
because you're going to put a lid on
this guy
and it's going to simmer on very low for
at least two hours you know give a stir
every once in a while make sure nothing
gets stuck to the bottom but that all
those flavors come together into it into
one thing sometimes passed and we just
have like a portion of the finished ragu
here at this point we're going to add in
it's a touch of cream i really feel like
this kind of helps round out the flavors
it's not a deal breaker if you don't
have cream here you want to add the
cream at the end because a long cooked
dairy is sometimes going to mask the
flavors that you spend all that time
building very carefully we're going to
throw in a touch of butter maybe a touch
more once you get the pasta but just a
little bit just like that and we're
going to set this aside and we're going
to cook our pasta and finish it right
into this pan they're looking good again
these are a fresh pasta they go pretty
quickly we're just gonna test one
another 25 seconds in the pan and then
we'll strain it and go right into the
sauce okay
if you feel like it needs a little bit
more liquid we're just going to add a
touch of the cookie all right our
pasta's been married into the sauce it's
got that cooked pasta sound finish it up
with just a touch more butter not too
much you can lift it with butter but it
also can mask itself don't overwhelm the
pasta with it we're gonna hit it with
just a little bit of cheese in the pan
we're gonna hit it with some fresh herbs
pasta sauce tightening up when you run
your spatula through it and that looks
good to me i'm gonna go right into the
bowl kind of finish it up a touch some
fresh herbs i like chive at this point
as with almost all pastas uh faro we're
gonna finish this with some chili pan
grittado so this is a calabrian chili
oil cooked into breadcrumbs and here you
have it this is our 20 ingredient pasta
this is cheicha muriki pork ragu topped
with chili pan gratato and some pecorino
this is a good afternoon spent
[Music]
this is a fantastic dish and we would
serve this proudly at the restaurant
work with what you have you know two
ingredients can just uplift up any pasta
shape into into the stratosphere first
thing we're gonna do when we get the
frascatelli in front of us is we're
gonna stir the egg in that really
finishes the dish
well the first thing you get when you
taste it is the pepper and the pork they
go together like peas and carrots it's
absolutely fantastic you cannot go wrong
with this dish making sure you get a
crispy bit in every bite is key
this is a dish that tastes like it was
cooked all day a lot of stuff going on
there pork
fennel black pepper tomato product that
really rich reduced red wine fresh herbs
the crispiness of the pan grittato
working with the chicha moriti you know
when i think about the scarpenoc with
brown butter and sage i'm thinking about
a really quick lunch or dinner even a
basic home cook and do it under 10
minutes and then moving on to the
carbonara i more think of that as a you
know you've got a plan same principles
building flavor on top of flavor on top
of flavor until you get to the end dish
taking the care with each one from the
pepper and the pork the goal is to put
five ingredients two ingredients or ten
ingredients into one dish ragu it's a
long process when i think of the dishes
it's not about trying to stuff flavor in
there it's about what works well
together you know you could make that
ragu any place between probably 15 and
20 ingredients if you're working that
long on dinner make it your flavors you
know
i don't think more is better it
sometimes can be it sometimes can be
worse really focus on which number is
going to fit my day my time my space my
you know ability i believe that any cook
can make all three of those dishes no
matter how skilled or novice you may be
at cooking each one of those was one
dish and that's really what you need to
look at which one dish made out of x
amount of ingredients is going to be the
best for me today if you can start with
that goal in mind you're going to end up
much better off at the end
[Music]
you